but then Dylan goes on makes a point
about anger the emotion of anger was
something that I've always been really
scared to tap into we have every right
to be angry right now I go between
either wanting to disassociate and like
hide under the covers or to like really
feel things it's a lot of effort and
scary and a lot of energy I've started
to feel anger in ways that I hadn't
before in ways that make me want to to
make progress when you feel growing
anger and more importantly when you feel
that that anger that wrath is a good
thing
you're almost certainly on the wrong
side of an issue it's not that anger is
intrinsically evil sometimes anger just
like the feeling of pain when you put
your hand on a stove sometimes anger can
be a good indication that something has
gone wrong but
when you act you should not be acting
out of anger